[Musique]
sachez que les physiciens sont des êtres
étranges et comme vous le voyez pas de
bol pour vous je suis un physicien et
des collègues des collègues physiciens
ont étudié un problème bien plus
essentiel pour votre vie que les
innombrables choses qu'on apprend la
télévision dans les livres il s'agit
j'espère que vous êtes assis et assise
il s'agit de la efficace efficace
tenez-vous bien de verser la pâte dans
une poêle à crêpes
alors bien entendu l'idée l'idée d'avoir
une crêpe sans trou mais sans utiliser
une quantité trop importante de pâtes
non plus je vous passe les détails sur
l'augmentation de la viscosité de la
pâte qui est fonction de l'augmentation
de la température cette à peu près comme
pour l'huile de vidange en fait les
collègues physiciens ont montré qu'il
fallait verser le liquide sur une
casserole très très inclinée en lui
imprimant un double mouvement d'abord de
rotation pour faire répartir si vous
voulez uniformément la pâte et ensuite
de redressement de la casserole afin
d'avoir une épaisseur constante en gros
les camarades physiciens ont montré avec
tout un tas d'équations over compliqué
ce que ma maman m'avait appris à faire
avec un simple tablier
sers-moi mais plus c'est quand même un
peu le thème de la conférence
nécessite de verser moins de liquide
dans la casserole en retour vous aurez
plus de galettes
l'idée n'est pas ce temps en soi
on va en fait résoudre ensemble le
paradoxe inhérent au proverbe de nos
grands-mères avoir le beurre et l'argent
du beurre
avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
signifie aussi que lorsque vous allez
recevoir les amis à la maison vous leur
servirez plus de verres mais moins de
liquide si vous faites des verres moins
remplis vous en tirez plus de la même
bouteille CQFD
un petit latinisme a placé ce soir c'est
toujours pratique
à la fois amphitriom et Harpagon c'est
même conseillé si on aime recevoir et
que le budget n'est pas une limité
il y a deux manières de faire cette
chose la première est totalement
malhonnête c'est l'astuce que j'avais
utilisé quand gamin je tirais l'agne de
la bouteille des parents et je remettais
à niveau avec l'eau du robinet
expérience vécue ça fonctionne très bien
tant que la bouteille reste au fond de
l'armoire et puis évidemment la recette
s'effondre dès que les victimes
s'offrent un verre
l'autre manière de faire est moins
directement malhonnête vous allez nous
allons manipuler les indices
environnementaux c'est le terme exact
des consacré de quoi s'agit-il on va
modifier des repères visuels notamment
afin de perturber le jugement de nos
invités un de ces repères est la taille
du verre
pour comprendre la chose regardez le
transparent qui est affiché
vous avez deux verres de jus rouge
spontanément
sans tricher à votre avis quel verre
contient le plus de jury rouge
on pencherait pour le grand verre en
vérité alors qu'on sait qu'on a mis la
même quantité de liquide dans les deux
verres pourquoi parce que notre œil
prend comme référence la taille du verre
justement
pour en avoir le cœur tout à fait net
comme clarinette on a récupéré 198
étudiants à l'université de Lilly Noize
c'est aux États-Unis et on leur a
demandé de servir des shots de 4,4 cl ça
fait pile poil une once et demi dans
leurs unités locales qui sont absolument
pas internationales il devait
il devait servir des shottes dans les
verres alternatifs
ils ont servi 30% le plus dans les
verres en fait large et bas en quelque
sorte si vous voulez ils ont compensé
l'effet d'optique
pour vous me direz ok ok mais ce sont
les jeunes ils ne servent pas des chocs
tous les jours que Dieu fait enfin on
l'espère en tout cas mais quand est-il
des serveurs professionnels les serveurs
professionnels on peut plus dire ça
maintenant on doit dire des mix sollogs
attention c'est le même métier mais ça
fait plus chic donc on a demandé à nos
mixologue de servi des shots et bardah
en belge donc bardah maintenant comme on
le sait tous ça n'a pas loupé ils ont
servi 20% de plus dans les verres larges
et bas en résumé du résumé si vous
habitez des amis à la maison privilégiez
des airs hauts et étroits de cette
manière alors que vous invitez croiront
à voir plus vous leur servirez moins
il me semble que c'est la main
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il me semble que c'est l'application la
plus efficace concrète et pratique
surtout pratique parce qu'on oublie
parfois la praticité de notre fameuse
Maxime du moins mais plus
passons maintenant à nos amis
restaurateurs là une expérience en fait
assez intéressante a été réalisée à
l'école hôtelière de Lausanne qui est un
établissement très très réputé ils ont
comparé devant un restaurant le service
des verres de vin sur deux semaines lors
de la première semaine la verdeva était
proposé à 5 ou 7 francs suisses bon
c'est Lausanne évidemment ils n'ont pas
l'euro donc les vers de 20 à 5 ou 7
francs suisses première semaine et
seconde semaine les vers de 20 étaient
proposés avec une suggestion un peu
pompeuse que vous avez déjà sans doute
vu du type accorde notre sommelier ou
une autre bonneumenterie du style
le transparent qui est affiché vous
indique les choix des clients en
fonction des semaines bien sûr
regardez les colonnes rouges lors de la
première semaine qui est indiquée
contrôle sur la gauche vous voyez qu'à
peu près une personne sur 4 un tout
petit peu moins de 25 % à choisir le
verre de vin qui pour rappel n'était pas
mis en avant dans le menu lors de la
seconde semaine qui est indiquée à
droite la semaine dite suggestion vous
voyez la colonne rouge on est presque à
75%. soit en vérité trois clients sur 4
qui ont choisi l'un ou l'autre des
verres de vin l'astuce dans l'astuce si
vous regardez les colonnes vertes c'est
que l'augmentation si vous voulez la
plus importante et le fait des vins les
moins chers un peu comme si on disait
moins cher mais plus de vert ou en
d'autres termes ou le client se dit ok
ok je suis un peu le dindon de la farce
ici mais j'ai pas envie d'être
totalement en plumé
bon ok ok mais tant qu'on est sur ces
histoires le restaurant là je dois faire
état avec vous de longues années de
recherches personnelles mais alors là
personnel a usé mon fond de culotte sur
les chaises restaurant
ne prenez jamais mesdames et messieurs
mais jamais l'accord mes vins le menu va
compris ou les vins du sommelier c'est
une arnaque intégrale intégrale
vous boirez des petits vins et connu
dont vous me direz des nouvelles mais la
seule nouvelle justement c'est qu'il
gagne à rester inconnu
donc on est sur ces histoires de ver de
vin ou de vin ouvert à votre avis quel
est le type de vin qui peut se servir le
plus facilement au vert
pas le service du verre de vin c'est pas
bien sûr d'extraire le liquide de la
bouteille ça le physicien vous dira qu'à
peu près tous les vins se valent mais
l'idée étant le pouvoir servir un verre
aujourd'hui un autre demain et un autre
après-demain de la même bouteille qui
devient de se fait une bouteille entamée
et d'avoir toujours un liquide tout
aussi bon
ne cherchez pas il s'agit pas de vin
rouge pas de vin blanc PAS DE VIN ROSE
pas de vin effervescent pas de vin
orange de vin bleu ou que sais-je encore
il s'agit des vins liquoreux comme le
Sauterne
le Sauternes c'est une magnifique région
de production qui s'étend du sud de
Bordeaux jusque Langon à peu près sur
2000 hectares vous êtes peut-être que
moi pour vous pour en tout cas pour moi
le terme hectare a souvent été très
familier avait portugaise à mes oreilles
si vous voulez mais ça représente à Sion
planaire n'était pas tout à fait
concrète
penser qu'un terrain de football c'est
cette dixième d'hectares donc vous avez
très exactement de 1857 terrain de
football à Sauternes c'est tout de suite
plus clair bien sûr donc
avec mes étudiants à l'université libre
de Bruxelles on a réalisé une expérience
assez subtile en tout cas on l'espère
qu'on appelle un test de résistance à
l'air de quoi s'agit-il en vérité on va
inventer le vin on va le mettre en
contact avec l'air et puis on va voir
comment le liquide se comporte s'il est
toujours tout aussi bon en général ce
type d'expérience se déroule sur une
durée de 24 heures guerre plus nous on a
un brin exagéré la chose un chouïa on
est monté jusqu'à 5 semaines après
l'ouverture
je vous résume on avait donc six
bouteilles du même vin du même vin de
Sauterne la première et c'est ici en
général je me plante je vous la première
avait été ouverte au moment de
l'expérience la seconde avait été a été
ouverte pardon une semaine précédemment
la troisième deux semaines précédemment
et ce jusqu'à la 6e bouteille qui a donc
été ouverte 5 semaines précédemment six
bouteilles 5 intervalles de temps et
puis on a bien sûr mélangé ces
bouteilles on les a anonymisés comme on
dit et on les a fait déguster par des
juges on leur demandant d'utiliser les
codeurs officiels classiques canonique
pour les vins liquoreux comme le
Sauterne alors le transparent qui est
affiché vous indique la représentation
graphique de cette opération qu'on
appelle le fameux diagramme en radar
vous voyez que les figures se
superposent en vérité les juges n'ont
pas été capables de distinguer la
bouteille qui avait été ouverte des
autres il nous pète il est capable de
distinguer aucune des bouteilles des
autres dans leur tête de juge il
dégustait exactement le même vin
pensez-y la prochaine fois que vous
ouvrirez une de ces bouteilles de vin de
Sauternes
elles se conserve magnifiquement bien
ouverte et entamée dans la porte du
frigo jusqu'à 5 semaines après
l'ouverture
un peu comme si on disait on peut voir
moins mais plus longtemps
on a commencé cette petite discussion en
signalant que les physiciens étaient des
êtres étranges sachez que les médecins
ne le sont pas moins
1765 a été défendu une thèse à la
Faculté de médecine de l'Université de
Reims par un certain pour four du petit
pour fond du petit Cesson non il ne l'a
pas choisi c'est comme ça c'est pour
vous les petits voilà
le titre de la thèse pour fou de petits
était le suivant j'espère que vous êtes
assis
austrea méripotos
répèteus en français de France cela
pourrait donner la traduction la plus
proche possible faut-il boire du vin en
mangeant des huîtres
tout de suite on constate que les
docteurs régents de l'époque avaient les
considérations aussi essentielles pour
l'avenir de l'humanité la sauvegarde de
l'espèce humaine que nos physiciens
crêpiers du début
mais quelle a été la réponse pour vous
du petit il a conclu par la négative il
ne faut pas boire devant en mangeant des
huîtres
de ma modeste expérience n'est pas si
idiot bon encore heureux vous me direz
mais en vérité les huîtres que c'est
extrêmement salé
certes c'est pas entre guillemets de
l'eau de mer dont la teneur en selle est
de 35 grammes par litre mais c'est
presque tout comme ce qui fait que tous
les vins blancs tel les chablis les
Sancerre les Pessac se font démonter
tous
presque tous parce que si on prend un
vin liquoreux comme le Sauternes dont on
a parlé
on a un accord magique on a un accord
régressif celui qui vient activer la
partie reptilienne du cerveau je sais
jamais si c'est la gauche ou la droite
le fameux accord sucré salé
tout ceci pour dire que notre pour vous
du petit avait eu le nez creux
quelque part il proposait de boire moins
voir pas du tout afin d'avoir plus de
plaisir gustatif
mais là où l'histoire se corse ou les
Romains s'empoigne ça vous fait un peu
comme vous voulez c'est qu'on a retrouvé
l'exemplaire à noter par le recteur de
l'époque un certain Louis Jérôme Rossin
il indique donc en marge de son calepin
la chose suivante monsieur pour four du
petit à menti ça part mal quand même
il faut en mangeant des huîtres boire du
bon vin blanc de champagne léger nos
mousseux il est à croire que l'auteur de
cette thèse président bachelier a été
déçu de mauvais vins que l'on débute à
Paris sous le nom de chez Jonathan ou
celui de Condrieu si ce gaillard avait
bu enfin vraiment j'ai plutôt des
huîtres en buvant de la tisane
d'épernée d'avis etc il aurait rectifié
sa conclusion et ce serait souhaité que
le mouvement
de citation
on comprend que le recteur n'est pas
extrêmement satisfait du travail du
docteur mais peut-être que le columfokai
s'est coupé d'Alès c'est si un brin
explication cela signifie littéralement
le coup et les maxillaires si vous
voulez les faux grandes ouvertes donc en
vérité le rector de Reims nous dit que
si le pour fou du petit avait mangé des
huîtres avec du bon vin blanc de
champagne il se serait souhaité le
gosier le plus large possible afin d'en
manger plus
un bon défenseur des produits du terroir
et de leur producteur leur lecteur et
moi proposait de boire plus pour que les
vignerons n'est pas moins de boire plus
pour que les vignerons n'aient pas moins
et là vous avez constaté qu'on a
introduit subrepticement en looté
une négation dans le moins mais plus qui
a fait la métaphore filée de tout
l'exposé cette négation
et bien elle nous emmène au dernier
point de notre affaire qui est un
élément de logique formelle si vous en
êtes d'accord nous terminerons par un
élément logique formel pourquoi la
logique formelle cher Monsieur parce que
ce sont les choses que j'enseigne à
l'université avec les mathématiques de
l'incertitude et oui et oui je
n'enseigne pas que l'agneau
cet élément de logique vous permettra
d'obtenir ce que vous voulez ou vous le
voulez quand vous le voulez et en
quantité que vous le voulez si ça c'est
pas du moins mais plus du moins mais
plus au carré c'est le beurre l'argent
du beurre le sourire la crémière et du
crémier en prime je sais pas ce qu'il
faut bref pour ne pas se gourer nous
allons partir d'un principe inébranlable
inattaquable indestructible c'est le
fameux
ex-fals c'est le dernier la tennis moi
je vois sur
ce que l'on souhaite en d'autres termes
si la prémicéphosse on peut démontrer ce
que l'on veut bien entendu ce principe
est utilisé tous les jours que Dieu fait
par l'homme de la rue afin de bâtir ses
argumentsations sur une bassesse mais il
peut avoir des conséquences inattendues
prenez par exemple la phrase suivante
si deux et deux font cinq alors je suis
Napoléon phrase elle est un peu
alambiquée oui ok
mais elle est vraie d'un point de vue
logique parce que deux et deux ne
faisons pas 5 il n'est pas fou de dire
il est vrai de dire que si deux et deux
font cinq alors je suis Napoléon
exfals
je suis Napoléon de dès que quoi
je suis la reine d'Angleterre ça ne
change rien que je suis Napoléon ou la
reine d'Angleterre
une ni de ces sages précepte vous
pourriez aller sur de cette conférence
vous tournez vers votre voisin ou votre
voisine et lui susurer alors et la chose
suivante qu'on va afficher pour la bonne
compréhension des opérations
si ce que je disais offrez moi un verre
de vin
votre voisin votre voisine n'a aucune
envie de vous offrir un verre de vin on
sait tous où ça commence on sait jamais
où ça s'arrête après vous allez lui
demander un dîner au restaurant une
ville pour les vacances une place pour
la prochaine conférence TEDx donc stop
halte là halte là on va considérer que
vous dites le faux mais disons le faux
le début de la phrase si ce que je dis
est vrai est faux et si la prémisse est
fausse l'ensemble de la phrase devient
vrai ex falso quad
patatras on est tombé à deux pieds
joints dans le piège et encore en nous
prenons en prenant garde de ne pas
marcher à côté du piège on a considéré
que la phrase était fausse et on en a
dérivé qu'elle est vrai cela ne se peut
c'est un paradoxe
la seule option qui reste c'est de
considérer que la phrase est vraie et de
vous offrir un verre de vin comme de
juste
et si ce que je dis est vrai la
conférence est terminée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]